hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to 60 seconds
re-atomized there was an update that
came out about a two years ago
um i say update it was another version
of the game it cost me more money so i'm
assuming that there's enough content in
here to justify that money spent
otherwise it would be a false
advertisement
otherwise i'd be pissed
but i'm assuming that i have faith in
the developers i'm assuming that i'm
assuming i have faith in the developers
and i'm assuming that they had faith in
themselves of me having faith in them to
put enough content in this game to
warrant another price tag
and apparently i bought it a few years
ago so i meant to play it but i didn't
hi mom and also i remember how to play
kind of ooh it's different
atomic drill scavenge survival challenge
scavenger huh
the blast claimed your scalp book as
well as our first aid kit even the map
got all torn up these items probably
won't be in high supply right now so we
need to learn to live without them
timmy's knowledge has now become
invaluable he must guide us through this
struggle towards a better tomorrow we
must care for him and protect him for
the scouts shall inherit the earth
oh
it's just individual like
challenges
which is exactly what it said it was so
that's not a lie that's a check in the
not lying from the developer's book
there is more stuff in here but uh also
i bet that's secret code i bet there's a
secret code to put in there
i bet there is
oh
if there isn't developers you missed an
incredible opportunity to justify your
ten dollar price tag
which i still have not determined if
it's good
or
legal
i'm watching you okay apocalypse oh i
can play as the mom whoa little boy
fat man
sarbamba you know i've never actually i
don't think i've ever beaten this game
so i don't know if
this would be the right thing to do
about it but i i don't i don't know
i don't know i'll just go fap man
that's fine i'll play as dolores though
okay so if i remember properly i need to
sprint and get stuff it has been a long
time since i played this
oh
hi kid
oh oh oh that's right that's the tuba
right right right right of course
grab
grab the daughter
oh no where is it i didn't even look
where the thing was
flop lamb
little timmy get in there
all right i see a gun
that's probably useful
yeah better than food who needs food no
no no hang on hang on hang on
oh my god i forgot how clunky and slow
it was
okay i don't know what this is
what's with this i don't know what that
is
that's probably important though i think
i remember that being kind of important
oh hell yeah oh hell yeah oh hell yeah
oh hell yeah
oh god husband husband of mine that i
love very much
soup
oh god there's so much good stuff
there
oh god
come on come on
one more thing oh no no that was a bad
deal
well that just goes to show how bad i
was at this game there goes mom
and that's kind of a handicap getting
off to the bat here oh no i'm just dead
right
they
ah
[Music]
well i perished but hopefully my family
survived i did it for them after all all
right let's try that again i just want
to play the baseline game to get an
understanding of exactly what i'm doing
here all right dolores you try this
again dolores okay we got some good
stuff there
nothing outside we need oh yeah
look at all this good stuff
come let's start here
get it
nice get it
okay
i know you can't hear the alarms over
your tube
uh uh-huh
nice not sure what the suitcase is for i
don't really remember but whatever
come here daughter
come here son
come here hubby
oh where's my hubby
where'd my hubby go there's my hubs
all right hubs in
kids in
i'm not in
that's okay
oh the map the map i can get the
map i can get it i can get it i can get
it this time i gotta i gotta i gotta go
i'm going i'm going
in in
in
okay i got that well that's good that's
a good sign for
me i'm very happy about that i'm
extremely happy
happy as happy as could be i don't have
the gas mask and i don't think i get the
axe i got a lot of good stuff on the
last one i really should have gone in
there
but i didn't
okay all of us made it into the shelter
just a second before the blast that was
a close one as long as we're all
together we can make it work down here
we remember hearing canned soup is
healthy for you our shelter used to be
fully stocked but somehow we always
found a better way to use stock supplies
instead of leaving them for an emergency
once we had a soup dinner party another
time we needed the rifle to help our
neighborhood watch in a vicious feist
against raccoons luckily some of the
supplies were left untouched one lock
hey look what we founded the suitcase we
grabbed upstairs good thing we didn't
unpack our holiday luggage
our shelves are full of cans we'll eat
from the cans we'll sleep on the cans
we'll even talk to the kids some of us
already do plenty of water beans we
don't have to worry about that for some
time this is the best stock shelter
we've ever seen we've never seen another
one but we're sure this is good amount
of supplies
okay
so this is great
however i do remember something about
you not needing to feed someone every
day which i'm not going to do because
that would be very dumb and
irresponsible of me so i'm not going to
do that
instead i'm going to take the
intelligent decision and i'm going to
play a game or two to relieve mood and
take our minds off the problems of today
and tomorrow and ain't playing games
good for you why not give it a try every
now and then
okay
did i play a
game i don't remember if i actually
played a game
did i play a game
we played hide and seek the longest
round we were able to play lasted for
around 10 seconds and that was only
because the lights went out for a moment
dolores is quite calm given the
situation ted is fine presses how well
mary jane is handling this situation
timmy's good well at least he was five
minutes ago
okay no one needs food
oh timmy can do it timmy can go into the
wasteland area is still irradiated okay
probably probably not the best idea to
go outside
good news everyone the government just
out there will be dropping crates filled
with supplies in our area they're useful
for something we should head out and get
those crates as soon as possible
grabbing some protection idea
all right well i don't have any of that
so i'm gonna prep an expedition and i'm
just gonna send him out there because
what else can i do
i don't really have anything to do
anything otherwise
so you know it was too dangerous to go
out there without any production so we
decided to stay indoors and listen to
the radio static is so relaxing do you
guys need water
do you really need water
nah they can survive another day nah
they're fine
they're fine another day
totally fine let me get out there
timmy don't get out there actually
that's a bad idea
perfect they're all good ted looks like
he's got one foot in the grave he needs
a drink right now fainting drinks
something fast well it's a good thing we
got water then vigorous enough to
withstand
well
it has become more and more difficult to
breathe in the shelter oh i was supposed
to select the game oh i'm so stupid i
forgot how stupid i was whatever it's
not worried about it
it's all good
it is what it is and i am what i am we
suspect that something may be wrong with
the ventilation maybe it got stuck
somehow but how we need to investigate
or we might suffocate
flashlight
prepper
did i do it i think i did it
whatever i did i think i did it good
the obvious thing to do with the vents
blocked is check what's blocking it
however when you shine your flashlight
on a hive of mutated insects things
usually go from bad to worse the angry
hive is gone but the insects did some
biting before they fled that's probably
fine it's been a while since we showered
the smells in this tiny shelter as far
from roses that we can get we had
thought of washing ourselves too bad we
didn't grab any soap along the way maybe
we could make something else do how
would bullets how'd bullets do that
oh
that's not good oh that's not good the
world this ended who cares about
showering we can get used to it adapting
shouldn't be hard it will be like a
camping trip well oh no that smell is
terrible don't puke don't switch the
stains
cover parts of the page oh good
everyone's sick great that's great this
is great great stuff gang great stuff
i'm gonna die let's do something today
something fun if we don't we might snap
and that's the last thing that we want
let's play a game of cards
all thumbs why all thumbs what's all
thumbs thumbs are all what why all
thumbs
oh we don't look so good we decided to
have a little poker game with the food
as kansas currency things got a bit
rough so rough we had ended badly for
our flashlight because managed to pieces
what a shame we're fine we're all fine
it's all fine
all is good what was that a rat raster
usually smaller than a cat and that's
with a double tail we can't let it get
to our supplies shoot it
shoot it
that's a lot more shooting than i
thought it would be
[Music]
oh well that's not good
our cans are safe too bad for the hairy
mutant guess we're still on top of the
food chain good for us damn our gun blew
up when we tried to shoot the thing okay
whatever um i don't have any medicine
and i don't know how a pungent odor got
you all to be that sick
so honestly this is your fault i made it
to day 10 guys i'm real proud of me i'm
real proud of me what me do
we always knew books were precious
they're the perfect weapon for waging
total war on insectoids of any kinds
fear will keep the local spiders in line
fear the scout handbook while chasing
them around the shelter we found a
misplaced water bottle that was a good
hunt
okay i get it dolores is injurious but i
don't have anything
i've got literally nothing timmy you go
out there you go out there be good
take all of our stuff
uh
[Music]
maybe you just go out with a map go out
with a map go timmy go go be gone timmy
i feel like dolores might be dead
dolores is not dead timmy went out into
the wasteland we don't know what we'll
do if he doesn't come back
delora her injuries need to be fixed
asap
we stumble upon a weird signal when
changing radio frequencies we're pretty
sure that the layers of the terrible
static and screams we could hear a voice
a voice speaking in a so foreign
language oh dear what if it's soviets we
should probably listen to it but what
about the children yes listen to it
oh
well that's not good i don't like the
sound of that
dolores you're still kicking huh wow
we relieved at first when we figured out
it wasn't soviets we heard turned out it
was canadians which isn't that much
better either way they're foreigners and
we couldn't understand what they were
saying not a word how disappointing i
know i know i know i know water yeah
water water i get it water yep water
water during our latest expedition we
ran into a smelly man and torn up
clothes we recognized him hymns as an
old bum named jim who used to roam the
streets of our town before the bomb fell
now he roams wasteland it looks like he
followed us home now he's banging on the
door asking if we want to buy a rock
well do we
can't say no to a rock
could be a good rock
could be a great rock
ah i guess i won't find out because i'm
kind of dead
we opened the door and greeted the old
man with a smile he was eager to show us
his bag filled with rich choice of rocks
and convinced us to take the one for
free for old times sake we agreed
carefully choosing the best looking rock
and the man left we can't complain it's
a good rock really also we claimed it
brings luck we'll see about that
well i guess we won't see about that
actually because dolores is dead oh well
i guess we're all dead now really really
dead
i don't know what to do maybe we'll pick
up some information yeah baby we will or
maybe we're all just going to die
i'm surprised that the game is keeping
on even though dolores is dead but i
guess it happens to us all
we were able to tune and get rid of just
enough static to listen to a very
energetic and lively speaker he seemed
well informed and mentioned a few
helpful tips that should make it easier
for us to survive the next expedition
you mean the one that timmy's supposed
to be on
we didn't expect to get a phone call so
soon after the atomic bomb drop yet here
we are we can clearly hear the phone
ringing outside it must be the public
phone booth on the other side of the
street who should go answer it what is
this
oh
ah mary jane you got this
go on mj
go on you're doing
great proud of you
is that a scratch when we answered the
phone we could clearly hear a gasp of
relief from the caller they introduced
themselves as survivors from a nearby
town of hill valley we started
exchanging information when the call was
cut short something must have gone wrong
in their side we hope they will get back
to us all right food
and water
why not let's live a little as long as
we have food and water we can stay
locked in but we'll have to leave
eventually it would be good to head
straight to safety
timmy had those comics so you know they
must do this all we need to do is make
contact with the military where is timmy
by the way where is tim
timmy
how how'd you do out there champ good
news the government made radio
broadcasts about extracting survivors
from our area the announcer asked
everyone listening to wait a while
longer and expect few of the
communication in a few days we'll be out
of here soon we were so afraid for timmy
but he came back from the wasteland the
silent wasteland had at least one
resident who managed quite well it was a
proud looking monkey we had no idea
where it came from the zoo maybe seemed
very friendly after getting a few pats
on the back and playing fetch it started
following us while we explored one of
the streets our monkey companion ran
away only to come back moments later
carrying a can of food it couldn't open
it it's himself but it was happy to
share it with us
at one point during our expedition the
monkey started making weird sounds
digging in front of us with a stick a
quick investigation revealed a few
bottles of water no one even tried to
open them the same couldn't be said
about those bottles of booze lying next
to them
ted hasn't recovered
if we don't cure mary jane soon who
knows what will happen i know last night
the whole shelter was woken up by ted
screaming bloody murder he was terrified
shouting something about tentacled
radioactive mutants on top of his face
turned out it was just mary jane
stepping on his head in the dark ted
took very personally and demands medical
care
we don't have any
we don't have any of that timmy's been
sitting there just staring into space
with something wrong maybe it would be
good to have a little chat with him
nah builds character
all right fine
is it about your dead mom kid hey listen
everyone's parents dies eventually
it's all part of the circle of life
even a word or two may be enough to
brighten someone's mood timmy seems to
be better now at least they seem to have
stopped getting so deathly ill didn't
you guys eat why are you still very
hungry why you still find soup all
around as well the other day we heard a
quiet knock on our door but when we
opened it we only found a suitcase on
the doorstep and there was no one around
it isn't signed but it sure looks like
it meant for us should we check what's
inside yes because i'm a greedy son of a
who opens every package that winds
up on my door that's not a good sound
turns out someone farted into a suitcase
and then put it on our doorstep
it was an innocent looking bottle of
water so we took a sip we thought we got
lucky but it was a lie either that water
was irradiated or it was some kind of
biological weapon it made all of us feel
pretty sick well we were already sick so
it doesn't matter how is timmy still
hungry
tammy how are you still hungry
how are you still hungry timmy you eat i
guess whatever mom's dead you ever think
about that all right
radio
day 20 give it up for day two zero
we're still plugging away
uh how fortunate we took the radio with
us we can probably listen to the music
they still play music out there don't
they
i don't know about dude fine water good
god you know what eat some more soup i
don't even care anymore i don't even
care peculiar it seems the whole shelter
has been shaking every couple of minutes
and it feels like it's getting stronger
every time this happens here it comes
again and it's way worth it's an
earthquake all right we gotta hold we
only have one thing to hold on to so i
guess it's not really a tough choice
did we save it earthquake or not
nothing's gonna stand between us and our
daily dose of radio static we were able
to grab it for it could fall down and
get smashed something else might have
might be broken but we don't know until
we clean this place up for an isolated
shelter we sure have a lot of
disturbances something's been making a
lot of noise since dawn and we couldn't
sleep seems to be coming from under the
floor and coincidentally we just found a
manhole that we could use to go down and
check what's going on
convenient manhole cover in the middle
of a room that you never saw before
where have i heard of that going into a
tight dark tunnel is not a good idea
especially with those weird noises
coming from it they're giving us the
creeps even up here alright you guys are
still sick that's what i've learned ted
and mary jane had been butting heads a
lot lately today they got into an
argument about movie characters
specifically who would win in an
ultimate battle peter pan or an army of
mutated cockroaches it's a tricky one
for sure and the debate is heated who
will come out on top well i mean peter
pan can fly so it doesn't matter oh
cockroaches can fly as well i'm gonna
have to go with a mutated cockroaches
wait
who
who voted who what
i gotta go ted you guys okay
jimmy you okay is your hair taking over
your body
you have a fungus on your head sleazy
looking traitor carrying an equally
scruffy bag on his shoulder paid us a
visit he offered us a simple one-time
deal for just one can of soup we get
with the bag and all of its contents we
can't see what's inside and the trader
gives us angry glances every time we
take a step towards some serious bag
yeah sure what's in the bag
i kind of want to know
oh
no way
no way oh
[Music]
okay we got a cat and that's great as
soon as the door closed behind the
trailer the bag started to violently
shake emitting screeching hellish sounds
terrified we backed up against the walls
when the beast finally escaped turned
out it was just an angry house cat the
fiend line gave us a menacing look and
promptly sat down in the corner to clean
itself scholar says shark off is that
its name well looks like the sickness
might actually take us so
here we go when we opened the shelter
door today we saw a letter lying on the
ground it was a cry for help from a
group of friendly survivors nearby or at
least that's what they claim to be
they're asking us to bring some supplies
over to a set location they're giving us
their word that they will not that will
not regret our generosity should we do
it
well given that we only have three cans
of soup left why not i always count on
the kindness of strangers hi sharokov i
don't like the way you're looking you
looked a lot nicer the day before the
authors of the note turned out to be
twin siblings a brother and sister they
greeted us happily and took us to a
small tent where they started handing
out the supplies we brought to a small
group of hungry survivors between them
there were people of all ages including
children the elderly and even a mom the
siblings shook her hand to proclaim this
the beginning of a new friendship they
promised to context us again soon
okay good
oh that was nice use the map to find a
location given by the military what do
you mean
we were able to receive another message
from the government the military is
preparing a rescue mission they want all
survivors to head to a specific location
in the area and then leave a sign that
someone is still alive and kicking
nearby the problem is they provided us
with geographical coordinates but we
need a map to find out where we're
supposed to be headed otherwise it's a
complete gobbledygook
well good thing i have a map a quick
glance at the map gave us all the
information we were required we left
them a message in a bottle how are they
going to find a messenger model group of
doctors knocked on our door today
requesting some supplies that would be
helpful in refilling their first aid
kits we didn't doubt they were real deal
for a second they did have lab coats and
everything shall we help them
well
i don't know if i can given that i only
have so much wawa left so i'm going to
not help you mr scientist we don't think
they were real doctors but just in case
they were we got rid of them quickly
before they could start charging us for
a home visit
[Applause]
we need water timmy noticed his old
telescope and a pile of rubble on the
other side of the street he got really
excited about stargazing again after all
the night sky is one of the very few
things that still look about the same
after the blast should we let timmy go
out and stare at the pointless sky
never stand between a child and looking
at the stars the profoundly beautiful
chasm of nothingness above our heads
timmy returned in the morning tired but
very happy says he saw a spaceship
flying by one with an american flag on
it surely that can't be true he's
probably making things up time to grow
up timmy all right fine food and that's
it that's all you get
sharkoff sure can take care of itself
but we can't help but wonder how much of
self-made cat it is just so happens we
found an address on its collar it's
unlikely that its owner is still alive
and a trip to the wasteland is always
risky should we ascend check it yeah
why not who cares if we die we're going
to reunite a pet in its owner we grabbed
our fluffy friend for a little stroll
through the waist only to immediately
run into a couple of gentlemen dressed
in trench coats fedoras and shades they
gritted their teeth at the side of the
cat and said they've been looking for it
apparently it belongs to their dear old
man who loves it dearly before we could
utter a word they took shark off
thanksgiving left the cat didn't seem to
mind so maybe it's for the best
all right well that was underwhelming
open in the name of freedom came a shot
from the outside the door we weren't
sure who claimed to be representing
freedom but we could hear was group of
people probably armed anyone who
introduced themselves like that is
planning to kill someone in the name of
freedom
should we open um
no i'm gonna go with it i'm gonna go
with
i'm gonna go with no
i'm gonna go with no i got a lock and a
key i've been intending to use this for
a while now don't know why i wouldn't
have but i'm not opening that door
we stayed silent until the group on the
other side of the door went away they
didn't show up afterwards so we figured
it was a wide thing
[Music]
what's that was that the was that the
military
was that the was that the military was
that the military did i miss out on the
military did i miss was that oh
[Music]
hello
hi we can make it work even in toronto
question is how do we find a boat to get
there we are just best way to get to
europe
i don't know about that
all right last drink of water everybody
good luck looks like that rock we got
from the old man a while really does
bring luck jim visited us today but
instead of rocks he was carrying a big
bottle of clean fresh water we don't
know where he got it but we were pleased
when he shared some with us should keep
us all hydrated and moist for a while
wait
does that
mean got a bottle
did we i don't know did we
i'm guessing we did maybe
cat why would there be a cat cat why are
you back
to our surprise we found sharkov back in
our shelter this morning we're not
exactly sure why or how it came back is
it our good care it appreciates our kind
hearts optimism or just our stockpile of
soup cans only time will tell all right
well
not really a stockpile anymore i'd say
timmy is bored out of his mind and won't
leave ted alone first he wanted to play
tag now it's hide and seek which are
both terrible ideas for a small shelter
like this ted is in a bad mood and just
wants to be left alone but timmy isn't
giving up how about charades okay
why not this really wasn't the best
matchup one moment ted and timmy were
calmly writing down riddles the next
they were screaming at each other
accusing the other of cheating how do
you even cheated this game
i don't know man i don't know curiosity
almost killed the catch hercule found a
tiny wire sticking out from the ceiling
and pulled it out plaster and debris
fell on her table topped off with a big
meowing furball what is this thing
anyway nobody remembers it being there
the cab might get angry if we take away
the wire so maybe it's best to leave it
or should we examine the wire
examine it
strange wire being in our shelter might
be something that we should investigate
we grabbed the cable and falled into a
rusty old truck parked in our neighbor's
driveway upon opening the door we were
confronted with two men wearing huge
headphones who looked extremely
surprised to see us they wiretapped our
shelter when we were asleep and they
were listening to everything we said we
gave them hell and marched back to our
bunker but why
why were they listening to everything we
said sure i'm up with the twins oh twin
siblings contacted us today they visited
our humble shelter map of the nearby
area planet city okay all right but
we're gonna die so
farewell
it's been nice knowing you
oh i'm still alive okay weird we were
happy to see them again we quickly
handed them our map
we have to find a good place maybe we
could visit them when the camp is ready
um well maybe our but um about that
oh we wish it would mark the end of our
stay in the shelter but it seems the
military has other plans all survivors
in the area were asked to head to the
nearby park and chop down as many trees
as possible to aid the evacuation effort
whatever that means we may as well join
in to speed up this whole affair
uh well about that
man i really didn't go on any
expeditions um
hello hi how are you good to hear from
you hello we were we're not lumberjacks
and we're not chopping down that park
maybe another time oh well about that um
soup soup
swoop soup
soup hey yeah the agents who are spying
on us are now at our door and want to
explain themselves should we hear them
out yeah sure you can we open the door
and then immediately a dead
well yep
that's what i thought
that is what i suspected
there were agents real live secret
agents on a government mission we saw
their identity cards briefly they
weren't listening in on us it was the
cat they were interested in they made a
request too wanting us to stayed them
with some of their top secret missions
in the future if we do that they promise
they will extract us to a government
safe house full of supplies and donuts
hopefully they come back soon with more
information and then we died
well that went terribly
that went just about as bad as it ever
could and i didn't even do anything to
try to avert my own fate i didn't go out
into the wasteland i didn't scavenge
anything except that one time and i got
nothing and broke all of my equipment as
soon as i used it
i was terrible i did everything wrong
what a load of well that was fun
but that was still the same old 60
seconds that i remember from before i
didn't actually notice anything new
happening
so is it all in these challenges
final countdown we survived the blast a
nice man on the radio the one with the
heavy accident promised rescuers would
come we must hold out until they arrive
99 days
from now
i there's no way
mcdoodles set out for a family
expedition but made the classic mistake
of forgetting their son little timmy is
a
i
love this okay there are some
interesting ones here but i love the
idea of this
timmy
all right fine
somehow uh timmy has to worry about
these
cretins
well there's a lot of stuff okay
alone in the shelter finally alone so
many possibilities so much space
thankfully ted and dolores left some
supplies behind they took the axe so
this rifle will have to do if anyone
tries to make trouble
okay
we've always thought life could be much
better that was before we got nuked now
we think of life as much
much better in a way oh
life could be much better you you're
right about that
you are right
all right whatever let's get on with
this what are these duo gonna do
what are they gonna do to me i'm too
strong for them memories are not we need
to keep our heads clear and get a grip
on reality okay whatever applied knock
on the door turned into a loud banging
oh no it's a bandit crew and they're
trying to break down the door good thing
we have this rifle we're gonna give you
the count of ten to get your mutated
yell no good geesters off our shelter
before we pump your guts full of lead
one two ten i'm not gonna shoot i'm
bluffing
i'm bluffing
i'm bl oh
oh
ah i see okay in the blink of an eye our
cozy post-apocalyptic home was taken
over but those gritty bandits it all
happened so fast
wow i screw i i didn't i did bad
yeah i see that yeah let me try that
again okay and now i'm gonna pump you
full of lead
now i'm gonna
before i wasn't and now i is going to
oh my gun's broken no that's not good we
were able to hit one of them with a
lucky ricochet that scared them off as
he was running away holding his buttocks
he cried over his shoulder we'll be back
and we're gonna get you your little jerk
one of them even lost his shoes yeah i
said escalated quickly and that damn
rifle is jammed perhaps we need another
plan we woke up to a dripping saw today
know there's something leaking from the
pipes oh
well i can't do that either so what am i
supposed to do about that
i i can't even go on an expedition how
am i supposed to be able to solve
anything we couldn't figure out so we
just assumed that it was a regular pipe
who would do in the event of and we've
been feeling a bit funny today though
probably no connection to the pipe none
whatsoever
he needs water now he needs water now
whatever every new smell attacks our
noses in this little shelter instantly
there isn't much we can miss so when a
single brick fell from the wall to
reveal in a tight opening our senses
were immediately invaded by a terrible
stench we should probably check that
hole out and see what the source of the
smell is
or we could ignore it
all right fine let's look
we looked into the whole fearing
something might come at us with claws
fangs or other parts instead we found a
dead rat who was trying to break into a
can of tomato soup filled miserably and
we have a feeling he will be luckier
than him so we confiscated it we gave
the wrap a proper burial in an empty can
he deserved that much
okay well that's good i got a can of
food last time the band is threatening
to light up this dump with torches to
finish the job since we don't have our
own torches to fight with fire with fire
is there anything else we could use
against them
um i'm gonna guess you bug spray
unless it's flammable and which it might
be
and maybe that's good
i'm alive
mission blowtorch was a success once we
heard the door open we unloaded the
whole can at the nearest torch causing
quite a fiery explosion the bandits did
not enjoy our explosive welcome and
scattered shouting something about
flamethrowers too bad they will probably
be back once they put out their flaming
hats
this is great it was great after all the
days we spent down here we're not
exactly clean we smell bad real bad it
didn't bother us until we know now and
now we're about to get sick why not take
a shower uh ammunition do i need i'd
probably need
i survived the sickness before i was
fine
i was fine before
i literally was totally fine and i need
those bullets the world has ended who
cares about showering okay
whatever this is a package with a pretty
ribbon on top waiting outside the no it
leads for my brave little scout love mom
is it safe to open absolutely not
it's probably a bomb or it was a lovely
present for mom
yeah right it must be a trap i sent by
those bandits shove that love with the
sun don't shine mom
yeah mom shove it up your ass
yeah mom straight up your ass how about
that trip to nevada we were postponing
for a while maybe we should go there
that's our first stop after we get out
of here how are you doing timmy uh we
need to give him water no
we need to give him water now don't tell
me what to do i bet at any moment i
could die from this sickness and it's
kind of just like a random chance thing
but i've been lucking out in the last
one
maybe moving away won't be too bad we
could probably make new friends meet new
people provided anyone's still alive
that is
today or never
today or never whatever we've been
hearing of strange noises lately is it
coming from the outside or is it
something that came into the shelter
with us could it be we found nothing we
feel like we might be going crazy we
should probably get busy with something
to keep us occupied before this gets
worse
having some fun made us forget about
what was it again
i don't know these bandits will surely
get in if we don't figure out a way to
stop them there's a half-broken wall
around and a trapdoor leading to the
shelter if something heavy was to drop
from there it might be enough to knock
out the invader or tour
i
but i died how would i have gotten those
things i don't have either of those i
can't go on an expedition
what do you mean maybe that was just a
dumb idea and i didn't want to do it
anyway we spent so long considering all
the possibilities we ended up doing
nothing at all before the bandits showed
up again and showed up they did
fortunately it sounded like these thugs
lost their flashlight and couldn't find
the bunker door in the dark at night
this year called the perimeter for some
time shouting about being scammed by
kindergarteners before remembering that
one of them is scared of the dark and
giving up next time we might not be so
lucky
okay
shut up timmy with your stupid coughing
you think you're fooling anybody nothing
nothing and nothing we could do nothing
let's see we need to get water yeah i
know there's a package outside wrapped
in so much crumpled newspaper it's
basically a shapeless blob but it has a
note attached it reads you're the man of
the shelter boy don't let us down dad
should we open it
now shove it up your ass dad
shove it up your ass we're certain this
is the bandit ruse so the package was
left untouched outside best case
scenario would have contained a mutant
tarantula
all right
maybe i should have opened those
maybe i should have we got scared a
little bit today when all of a sudden
our map just fell off the wall maybe our
shelter is haunted when the map fell
down to reveal some sort of safe behind
it we don't remember installing it but
we probably can crack it well we
technically have all the time in the
world should we try
why not
okay we're not sure how or why the map
just decided to slide off the wall but
we're lucky that it happened inside the
dusty safe we found some supplies all
right
good
what was that sound oh no something or
someone is below us it's only reasonable
to go down and check it out how about
using that manhole in the corner
[Music]
okay who would have guessed that a
secret wine cellar under our house
thanks to our trusty fast flight we were
able to hunt down some of the remaining
bottles the content only tasted more
like water than wine but as long as it's
liquid we're happy all right timmy's
gotta get drunk timmy's gonna get drunk
oh it's a party down here
all right you know what it's a party why
don't we just uh
gobble up some extra food maybe you
won't die from sickness something needs
to be done before the band is returned
we know for a fact that at least one of
them is barefoot if something sharp
enough was to be scattered on the ground
we could really make them feel the pain
well it ain't gonna be the map i'm gonna
do checkers
build little checker pieces they're like
legos
painful as hell in part two it's like
that's six
the checker pieces were set in place as
predicted
the at least one of the invaders was
bare developer
the at least one
need i remind you how much this cost me
ten dollars this cost me ten dollars and
you come in here with something like
this the at least one
has predicted the at least one and soon
terrible screams could be heard outside
your offices
seems like good old american checkers
are much worse than that new danish
invention legos the pain will be back we
know that you're in there and that
you're alone they shouted before leaving
maybe should eat something an extra
blanket no longer sir
well i mean i did eat something but
whatever
there's an armed and dangerous woman
outside fortunately she's out of ammo
she tells us that she hunts the wild
beasts of the wastes and right now she's
on a trail against a giant mutated
spider we're pretty sure she lost her
mind what are you gonna do with that
spider lady put it on a leash she
promises that if we help her she will
return the favor someday no
i need these bullets for stuff and
things
more like to put a
bullet in a bandit's head
or ass an armed person who murders
things for a living giant mutated
spiders in our neighborhood we don't
want to have anything to do with that
stuff goodbye lady
how are you still hungry is it because
you're sick traveling salesman paid us a
visit today introduced himself oh
i don't have four bottles of water
i do have four bottles of water but i
couldn't possibly give up four bottles
of water
oh oh it's the other way around
i uh yeah i don't need the cards unless
i do need the cards why would i need
cards over bullets i have bullets i need
food do i need food
don't i have enough food to last
couldn't i only got to make it to day
30. uh why not you know what screw it
i'm probably not going to regret this
i'm probably definitely not going to
regret that
probably definitely not going to regret
that probably definitely not going to
need those cards immediately after
we made a deal
right now should get some water
why are you so goddamn hungry last thing
we expected to hear while sitting in the
fall at shelter was a trumpet it was
played by someone who's clearly not a
trumpet player and who had probably
never heard a trumpet player in his
entire life he came with a friend who
knocked on the door and demanded that we
let the merry men enter so they could
take from the rich and give to the poor
should we let them in how about no
i'm i'm little timmy i'm a kid shove the
merriment up your ass
shove the merriment of your ass i'll
cough on you we didn't answer the
peculiar calls and kept the door locked
until the noises outside faded away
we're not exactly sure what we want
those people to come back they sounded
harmless enough but can harmless people
be trusted in these troubled times they
might be worse than those who don't seem
harmless at all whatever you say man
we have plenty of distant relatives but
none of us is mean as much as to us as
aunt
auntie ada she lives in the country so
there's a good chance she's still
figuring her cow counting machine and
not worrying about nukes raining down on
her hen house too bad we don't have a
photo of her or do we i don't i don't
have that book
i don't have that book i don't have the
book and so we were left with no photos
no news and no happy thoughts the world
is too cruel
yep sure we're freezing cold outside the
bands probably expect us to huddle in
the corner with a blanket
water water on the ground it'll freeze
they'll slip slide and get bland but
there were also cards there but i bet
that wouldn't have been the better
choice we pulled one of the most obvious
pranks of all time by spilling water on
the pathway outside and letting it
freeze overnight we laughed a bit too
loud they were took offense and pledged
in so many derogatory words some of
which they clearly invented to return
with vengeance all right whatever
today we met a bunch of people dressed
in what looked like halloween doctor
outfits they couldn't be a field
hospital moving from place to place they
promised some of their supplies got
eaten by something that looked like a
sasquatch
they think of
i'm sorry i can't spare any
i need to last nine more days we don't
think they were real doctors
get out of here
get out of here we found a box outside
wrapped in what seems like six different
types of wrapping paper the note says
mama's making me write this i hate you
try not to die or something whatever it
could be a bomb or something even worse
should we open it to find out
shut up mary jane
i don't need you it's all a lie
all just a lie to try to get me to open
the door this is a banter trap and we're
sure of it mary jane could never have
written such a nice note
yeah i didn't think so ammunition is
missing there's no way it was stolen it
has to be or somewhere we need to find
it
yeah i need that ammunit i need the i am
on a mission oh good i found it
excellent
the first thing we found was a forgotten
deck of cards dolores used it for a
solitaire back in the day until the kids
lost a few of the cards we can now play
semi-solitaire found it covered by a can
all right good we're about to finish our
dinner if you can call it that when we
heard someone knocking out the door it
seems to be a traitor who is very
interested in ammunition how about that
no
go away
go away i don't need anything from you
i don't need anything i've got five more
days and i need everything possible to
survive
we could tell the stranger was
disappointed but it was never our
business if ever was the time to get
used to life by disappoint by being
disappointing the end of the world is
probably it shove your disappointment
off your ass i don't care the bandits
will surely be back one of their biggest
advantages is that way they have the
numbers and they know it what if we made
them think we'd brought reinforcements
by playing the radio which doesn't
really have a signal but yeah
we built a scarecrow outside using empty
soup cans and we turned on what used to
be the radio theater channel and put the
volume on max luckily something was
still playing there probably an old
recording set on loop the combination of
a loud broadcast and a few cans dangling
in the woods turned out to be terrifying
as soon as they approached the bandits
turned back screaming about monsters
from mars invading the earth with heat
rays really as if the nuclear war wasn't
enough
all right
today we were visited by strange little
man introduced himself as a traitor he
insisted his prices are so low that it's
practically like cutting his own throat
least we could do is take a look at his
offer although for some reason we don't
really trust him
yeah i don't trust you either go away
go anyway and i don't need you despite
his desperate attempts to sell us all
kinds of things useless and not we
turned down the man's offer it's
probably for the better he did look
quite untrustworthy yeah i know
oh i know
soup and water because i have some to
spare i'll save that
stranger pushing a rusty wheelbarrow
filled with all kinds of goods stopped
by today he claimed he's a trader
looking to barter i don't need water i
don't need any of that i only gotta do
two more days left
we refused to trade hopefully we made
the right choice but the trader was not
too happy about this well shut up well
shut up
i thought i drank didn't i drink some
water last night didn't i drink some
water
woman came by with a creature she claims
as a camel provided the camels have five
legs the animal is carrying a pack of
goods for trade
well i don't need any of that i don't
really need it i have enough i don't
really need it unless i need water and
jiffy i don't know am i about to win
this
am i about to win this is it's a final
countdown or something
in the end we decide her offers were not
for us maybe another time if she ever
comes back have some soup i guess the
relentless thugs are approaching again
we didn't prepare anything maybe they
will show us murthy no not after the
hell they went through they mean
business let's hope they slip on the
ladder
wait
we didn't prepare anything what do you
mean we didn't prepare i didn't know i
never thought how could i not prepare
anything you didn't tell me to prepare
anything you didn't have me an option to
prepare anything i'm gonna eat some soup
oh
dolores ted mary jane pancake and shark
finally returned and jumped the thugs
from behind biting kicking hissing
barking throwing punches and wrapped
christmas presents the bandits barely
escape with their lives merry christmas
you filthy animals now let's unwrap
their presents oh it's soup and more
soup
they're all soup oh
i did it i i never really win this game
i know it was an individual challenge
but maybe they just made that so that i
could kind of feel good about myself but
hey
that's pretty good
i don't know what these are but that's
pretty good
wow
all right so that's 60 seconds i deemed
the value of this update up to thine
choosing because maybe i didn't explore
enough to the original game to know
exactly what's different in the first
place because i was not good at it and i
still am not good at it i pick by random
chance and that's how fate should be
completely random thank you everybody so
much for watching if you want to see the
other videos of 60 seconds and also the
space sequel 60 parsecs which i should
probably play again i only played it
once you can find them in the link in
the description below thank you
everybody so much for watching and as
always i will see you
in the next video
bye-bye
[Music]
you